我們來看看幾個例子
今天我所做的事
我沒有再談論我們所擁有的事
在過去我擁有過幾個例子
我在1997年開始了這個生意
在這段時間中
我經歷了幾個很嚴重的事件
一是亞洲金融危機
第二是科技爆炸
幾個不同的事情
在這段時間中
你會擁有更有趣的機會
我們開始
我們回到1998年
在1998年下旬
我告訴你我經歷的搜索
非常簡單
因為我對各種不同的生意有興趣
我通常只會得到單位
我跟著這兩條價值線
當我讀書的時候
每個問題都會出現
我都會從一開始到最後
因為這真是最好的教育
如果你想擁有教學
知識基礎和資料基礎
你必須擁有
所以只要一步一步走過
就非常有幫助
第一點我經常檢查的
是新的低清單
最低清單是書
最低清單是筆記
最低清單是這個
這對我來說
比新的高清單更有興趣
其實我沒有更多的副本
我把那些刪除了
所以我請他們做重複
而數字不是正確的
我看了一些
在我認為是
我認為是
9月或是8月
當市場大約是28
所以這是46
不是正確的
所以我認為大約是
28至30
現在你看到這一個
什麼是第一點
會跳到你身上
有人給我一個快速的閱讀
是的
我找到
高低清單
對
還有什麼
是的
對
還有什麼
如果你是投資者
其實你不太在意
我們之前的貿易
我當然在意
我告訴你我所找到的
首先是看價值
如果價值不合適
我不太想發展
所以我們知道價值
我們知道價值是什麼
是的
這是一個很好的點
那是什麼是
書本價值的法律
每次你看到
書本價值
你都會想說
書本有什麼
書本有多少
什麼
這很簡單
你叫它28
然後你得到
11.5萬個股票
大約300萬多
低於300萬
就這樣
你不用去做所有的快速的
你會看到
現在的工作資金
差不多是300萬多
當然這就是Q3的結局
在商店
你會知道Q3的結局
這是你
這就是你
一個很快的
經濟知識
真的會幫助你
所有商店都會建造
大量的圖像
在上一季
所以你回顧前幾年
說什麼是正常的
因為它們真的會
在年底收到很多錢
你會說
300萬多
差不多整個書本價值
大概275萬多
都在工作資金裡
其他東西都會交換
所以你可能會
在後一季
會看到100萬多的現金
如果回顧前兩年
你會看到
200萬多的物資
加上100萬多的物資
如果你做一點多的研究
你會看到
整個房子
基本上是現實房子
所以300萬
你正在交換
大概300萬多
200萬多是物資
100萬多是現實房子
所以你會看到
下半身的保護
我們知道的就是賺錢
錢流
你最想賺到的
基本上就是
預算稅和稅務
不支薪
如果你想比較
那是不支薪的資金
在商業上
讓你感受到
賺到多少錢
給我一個快速的感受
那是多少錢
如果你很擅長
你不應該
一秒鐘就知道了
你總共有13%
擁有800萬
800萬
850萬
你總共賺到100萬
110萬
那你所賺到的錢
賺到多少錢
在商業上
總共
你總共賺到200萬
在物資
然後100萬在建築物
然後200萬在物資
大概100萬的現金
總共賺到200萬
賺到的資金
總共賺到110萬
所以你賺到的資金
大概50%
在那個時候
你賺到的資金
大概50%
在那個時候
這不是壞的商業
你不應該
一秒鐘就知道了
你會說
商業上
我不在乎其他東西
大概賺到的資金
資金的價值很低
基本上是
賺到的資金
再加上
100萬在現金
賺到的資金
基本上
大概賺到的資金
總共賺到100萬
所以這不應該是壞的商業
首先
你會檢查
為什麼這整個東西
在那個時候
會分開
會失去
當你這樣說
你會說
這不是壞的
如果我擁有整個商業
記得你總是
認為自己是商業家
如果我擁有這個商業
如果我能夠
在這個價值上
購買整個商業
你可能會想擁有
其實這不是壞的名字
很多人都認識
Timberland是一個品牌
對嗎
所以那時候的原因是什麼
事實上
那是亞洲金融危機的高度
他們所有的對手
尤其是Nike和Revolve
他們的銷售
尤其是在亞洲
跌倒了
所以整個困境
所有的物品
所有的商店
鞋子
國際品牌
任何有亞洲的經歷
都會分開
但是還有什麼呢
所以你嘗試
你嘗試去檢查
有什麼其他人
在考慮這件事
你可能沒有
你可能沒有聽他們的聲音
但你想知道
有什麼其他人在考慮
所以你檢查
有什麼人在考慮
結果沒有人在考慮
沒有人在考慮
如果一家公司
銷售一億
這家公司是個理想的公司
是個大品牌
所以為什麼沒有人
在考慮這件事
有什麼可能
你能夠猜測的原因嗎
是的
他們沒有資金
他們不去資金市場
所以他們不去銷售
這對你來說是好還是壞
對投資者來說是好
這對你來說是好
你回頭看十、五十年
價值線的好處是
你會看到他們
真的有什麼需要
那些錢
你找到什麼
在這幾年來
這家公司
已經在增長
並且經濟財產
也在近年來提升了
但是也都已經頗為有利
因此他們的金融市場
仍然非常少
還有什麼其他原因
是什麼擁有的狀況
是的
這是家庭擁有的嗎
你對家庭擁有什麼意思
家庭擁有
他們擁有40%
他們擁有多少投票
他們擁有100%的投票
他們擁有100%投票
有100%的投票 基本上有98%的投票
所以馬上就把整群人都打掉了
然後你會看到投資者
在過去的過程中基本上都在反應
你可以做一個快速的資料搜集
這就是為什麼我會說
投資者應該應該
調查一個記者
因為我們有一個記者在這裡
我肯定如果我問記者
看看這個問題
你知道的
第一個問題
你會說
我會去問所有這個問題
然後你很容易就能找到答案
非常快速的
所以你必須要有一個非常活躍的
非常有興趣的思想
然後你根本就沒有
能夠滿足任何高貴的答案
否則你根本就不可能
在這個生意裡
所以你去
然後你會發現
其實有很多不同的
投資者的資料搜集
現在你有一家公司
持有40%
持有100%的投票
而大部分投資者
都沒有投票
你沒有資料搜集他們
而且有很多投資者的資料搜集
所以你必須要知道
如果你不知道
有關這個生意的事情
如果你是其他投資者的95%
你會得到什麼結論
如果你是一個普通的公司
或是投資中心的投資公司
或者是投資中心的投資公司
你會得到什麼結論
現在你會得到這些資料
請問
如果沒有足夠的資料
可以觸碰投資者
所以就沒有什麼方法
對
還有什麼?
我應該會覺得
問題是偶然的
對
還有什麼?
是的
你們還不夠敷衍
你們真的擔心
管理人員可能會把錢
從公司撿走嗎?
可能會把他們的書寫出來
因為他們控制了所有東西
他們根本沒有
他們根本沒有限制他們的行為
而且他們有很多法律
告訴你們
他們在說什麼
所以你們要做什麼?
你們要做什麼?
是的
這是一個東西
什麼?
檢查法庭記錄
絕對的
你們會下載每一篇
法庭記錄
每一篇法庭記錄
從一篇文章上
把他們看出來
所以我剛才說
如果你們沒有好奇心
如果你們只是想做
因為你們想把錢撿走
可能你們不會做這個
你們必須真的要想
我只是好奇
什麼事發生了?
這不是好奇的
你們必須把每一篇文章都撿走
這是一件很重要的事
你們要把每一篇文章都撿走
就像我這樣
第一篇文章
要花幾分鐘
你們要看那篇文章
你會說
所有的問題
都會帶給你們
所以
我可以找到
所有的案件
都會成為一件事
其實這基本上是一篇法庭記錄
法庭記錄
有人會說
他們曾經提供一些指示
但他們沒有提供
然後那位投資者就發瘋了
所以那位投資者就發瘋了
你可以看到他的防禦
你可以看到他對那篇文章
他就說
你知道嗎
我不會再這樣做了
我不會再跟街上說話
我不會再提供任何指示
我不會再再提供任何指示
我不需要對任何人說
我不要再提供任何同意
所以這就是最好的事
這就是最好的事
所以下一步
你們要做什麼
如果他們真的把這個方向
的話
他們會說
可能他們不是騙子
但他們真的就是好管家
我們知道他們是怎樣的
他們是好人
你很努力 但你不確定那些數字
你不確定那些數字 但他們是在賺錢的
但他們是在賺錢的 如果他們是製作人
當然 還有什麼可以做的
你怎麼知道他的性格
你嘗試去找他鄰居
好主意
他們會給你他們的名字
好 什麼叫你 告訴鄰居
告訴他們 但我擔心
可能是市場擔心
可能是市場擔心 他們可能不認真
可能是市場擔心 可能不認真
你怎麼說 去死吧
你會去死嗎
我嘗試…
但很多人會告訴你 去死吧
但這是個好試
還有什麼
對 當時沒有Google
但這是個好主意
你回答我的問題
你必須去…
再一次…
我剛好遇到一個記者
但我總是以這個工作
作為一個記者的調查
有很多建設商業的人
也有一個很大的性格
有一個歷史可以去調查
他們是有什麼樣的人
他們做什麼
他們的處理
並不那麼難
但你必須…
很多專業經理人
不應該認為這些事物是一部分
但我告訴你 你是5%
如果你去到5%
但如果你去到5%
這就是你所做的
你去看他們的社群,去聖地公寓,去見大家,你將自己變成那樣的一部分。
然後你向他們的朋友、家人、鄰居介紹,不要只叫他們,去那裡,在那裡過幾個星期。
這是值得的,值得的。
只要你能夠在這時刻,去找到他,去找到他。
他對社群的做法是什麼?
鄰居和朋友對他有什麼說法?
這告訴你更多的這個個人物。
你希望找到家人的動力。
這位同學其實是唯一在高中畢業的學生。
從來沒有去過高中。
一個相當簡單的男生。
但是一個很好的男生。
他已經很健碩了。
去聖地公寓,但不太專注。
但更有趣的是,他有個兒子,他也去過商業學院。
他其實是我的年齡。
他在30歲的時候。
他已經當了公司的行政總裁。
所以我做了所有的提示給你們。
我做了更多的。
我找到這個兒子,所有的父母和兒子在一起。
我找到一個在一起的兒子。
他其實是我的朋友。
所以我邀請自己在一起。
所以我跟兒子一起在一起。
我們就變成了很親密的朋友。
然後我真的知道在家裡發生了什麼事。
是Turnaut。
這是我遇到過的一個最令人尋常的家庭。
他們是最有價值的人。
他們很棒。
他們也成為了很棒的行政總裁。
所以後來,這家公司還在30歲的時候。
所以你可能會說,我錯過了什麼嗎?
你可能會說,我錯過了什麼。
其餘的95%只是不知道。
或者他們的工業制度不允許他們做任何事情。
所以你做什麼呢?
你做什麼?
買。
你想買多少?
假設你有一百塊。
多少錢?
什麼?
十。
四十。
什麼?
多少錢?
兩百塊。
兩百塊?
好。
我喜歡在這個課堂上聊天。
因為你們還沒被淘汰。
現在如果你們去參加金融會。
第一件事,人們會告訴你,
噢,你不要做多於25個基礎點。
然後你去50個基礎點。
你去100個基礎點。
他們會用一個基礎點。
所以每個數字都很大。
你知道嗎?
我們要去50個基礎點。
那是個很大的事。
這就是這樣。
所以保持自己的無辜。
因為現在你所想的東西是普通意識。
你想想,你花了多少努力去做這件事。
你想想,它是多麼好的。
它有幾乎沒有下跌。
你約五次的交易。
然後我做的第二件事。
我去很多不同的銷售店。
為什麼在過去幾年來,
銷售價格漸漸提升了?
結果在內城,
尤其是內地市場,
所有小孩子都想要
小鞋和衣服,
還有衣服和衣服。
所有銷售店的經紀人都說
他們沒有足夠的貨物。
你看看他們的國際生意。
他們的生意在亞洲,
其實是少於10%。
他們做的東西,
是少於10%。
10%,
10%的27%。
所以你計算了,
他們全部都失去了。
所以什麼?
你減少了5%的賺錢。
所以,
我放了一大堆東西。
有人知道之後會發生什麼事嗎?
在未來兩年,
你們都有網絡,
你們可以馬上查看。
真的嗎?
為什麼你們要聽到這些?
你們只做什麼你們想做。
因為他們說,
你們現在是因為
別人告訴你們,
他們同意。
你們現在是因為
你們必須做這個。
你們必須查看。
所有這些東西
不少於5分鐘就能找到你們。
否則,
你們就不是好分子。
如果你們不是好分子,
你們就不會成為好投資者。
真的。
所以,
你們必須,
最基本上,
你們必須
非常非常有利。
在未來兩年,
這件事情
發生了7次。
事實上,
在這段時間內,
賺錢的趨勢,
你們仍然沒有任何危險。
不像你們在
在雙倍的公司
之後
發生了大量的攻擊。
賺錢的數量
從來沒有超過15次。
但是,
如果你們從5倍
到15倍,
賺錢的趨勢
在這段時間內
增長了30%一年,
這會增加。
而其他人,
他當了行政總裁。
他有了完全不同的想法,
如何經營一家公司。
他非常有意義。
他是最有意義的人,
他遇到的。
他仍然是。
所以,
他不願意
開會。
賺錢的趨勢,
而是開會。
他第一次開會
他知道
有多少人出現。
他、我,
還有另一個開會。
三個人。
最後的開會,
我去到2000年,
2000年結束的時候,
房間完全被封閉了。
大約有50、60個人。
大街上的房子
封閉了。
所以,
我才知道
我必須賣掉。
我賣掉了所有東西。
總之,
我們回頭說說。
你知道,
時間有點變動。
這是一年半前。
是的。
你擔心1994年
和1996年
發生了什麼事嗎?
特別是1996年。
因為那是
法律上發生的時期。
他們有時期。
發生了什麼事?
他們在那時候
做了錯誤的事。
因為他們的產品
不是正確的。
他們建立了他們的生意
在這類型的水平上。
他們是第一位
在這類型的水平上
發展出來的。
所以,
他們把水平上的
水平上的水平
和沒有水平上的水平
分開。
在市場上,
那是一個錯誤。
他們把市場混淆了。
他們把他們的責任
分開了。
然後,
他們受苦了。
但是,
那一年,
他們的收入
仍然上升了。
他們有了一年的
糟糕。
大多數時候,
他們將他們的生意
實現得很完美。
是的。
對,
當你跟他們的生意
有關係的時候,
他們的生意
會不會
讓他們的生意
變得更好?
會的。
這就是為什麼
他們後來沒有購買東西。
他們不需要。
他們已經購買了
28年代的所有東西。
你知道嗎?
當他們上升了,
他們就只需要
把自己的屁股放在上面。
他們不需要做壞事。
購買好生意
是一件好事。
生意要照顧自己。
就像Chay說的,
他們上升了,
他們的生意
實現得很完美。
是的。
你花了多少時間
在購物前
做生意?
其實沒有多於
幾個星期。
所有的事情
實際上
不需要太長時間。
但當事情發生的時候,
你只需要
每天晚上
做生意。
每天晚上做生意。
這就是為什麼
我的妻子
其實在這裡。
我還記得
我做的一整晚。
這種機會
很少會出現。
所以當它出現的時候,
你必須把它捨棄。
你必須完成
所有的事情。
但你必須做得很快。
這就是為什麼
你必須
每天都要訓練自己。
你不必做壞事。
放東西進銀行,
那是沒問題的。
你不必購買任何東西。
但當機會出現的時候,
你必須奔跑。
這就是我做的。
你必須完成
所有的事情。
這不需要太長時間。
但你必須做得很快。
是的。
你平時會找到
螢幕上的東西嗎?
我喜歡讀那些東西
主要是因為
在自己身上
是一個好活動。
我不需要找到任何東西。
我學會了。
我對所有的生意
都很感興趣。
這就是為什麼
當機會出現的時候,
在幾秒之內
你會知道。
你會嗅到它。
你如何
去發揮它的氣味呢?
唯一的方法就是
每一頁讀一頁。
價值線是非常好的
因為它能把
各種不同的數據
和各種不同的年齡
放在一年內。
所以
這是你最容易
學會了
很多不同的生意。
是的。
你投的成本
是多少呢?
我沒有投的成本。
但是我投的成本是
非常低的。